[Musique]
bonsoir quelqu'un
qui
sifflement parfum mon auteur je vois
qu'il me pisse le fils de freestyle sur
notre droite
bonjour
1 2 3 puis je te vois plus je m'accroche
à toi
et j'ai craqué sa croix 1 2 3 puis je te
vois plus je m'accroche à toi toi plus
moi ma faute j'ai craqué ça se dit je
crois que c'est mon téléphone qui sonne
personne
vite vite vite vite vite
messagerie ne t’étonne pas si je
t'appelle plus les sentiments sont des
soucis moi quand je la vois pas je suis
triste
la gentille et moi je fais bobo
plus je m'accroche à toi plus moi ma vie
j'ai craqué ça à toi
[Musique]
j'ai craqué
téléphone sonne vite vite vite
[Applaudissements]